by travelpod member here's a repeat not  exercise my teaching undergrad showed me  take any note an octave apart using both  hands in four note groupings you  alternate between fingers 5 4 3 2 1 5 4  3 2 1  and you accent every 4th note or every  every four notes 1 and making sure that  my fingers get out of the way quick  enough so that the next note will sound  [Music]  the teacher work with this past year  healthy realize that the thumb works  very differently from the rest of the  fingers and that the side-to-side motion  is more comfortable than up and down now  taking that into consideration when  you're doing repeated notes and stuff  your fingers curling this way and  getting out of the way your thumb will  be I guess curling this way this  side-to-side little  so in order to transpose this I could  either read this in a different Clough  or I could just figure out what's going  on and apply it to different keys  [Music]